good morning everyone
um i'm rohini ponding i'm a professor of
economics at yale and director of the
economic growth center
it's my great pleasure to welcome all of
you to this concluding event
of our three-day celebration of the 65th
anniversary of the masters in
international development program
and it's also part of the 60th year
celebration of the economic growth
center
so when i started as the director of the
growth center last year i
spent some time just going over the
archives of
the economic growth center and id
program
i think what was striking to me was just
what a fertile period
the 1960s was i think more generally for
development economics but especially at
the growth center
you know this 1960s marked the end of
colonialism in most parts of the world
and there were a lot of open questions
about you know
both how should low-income countries set
their course for the future
but also importantly what were the roles
and responsibilities
of academics and policy makers in richer
countries
and these discussions were really
mirrored in the economic growth center
and the researchers who came through in
the student discussions
uh one of the first markers of one of
the first activities of the economic
growth center was the country studies
program
which sent faculty members like
alejandro carlos diaz
to latin america and they found strong
networks in those countries which
continued after they came back
and i think as we look at the growth
center
past present and future i think it's
these links with
researchers across the globe that is one
of the things that at least i
i believe edc should be very proud of
latin america was i think central to
this in the 1960s there was a lot of
engagement
between what was happening in latin
america with discussions of economic
development more broadly
and with the growth center and so we're
delighted to
welcome edmar basha and anna cecilia
filer who will lead a discussion on the
brazilian economy
so let me start by introducing both our
panelists
so anna cecilia filer is a visiting
assistant professor at the economic
growth center
and the yale economics department she
earned her phd from new york university
and has worked at princeton university
and university of pennsylvania
in her research she combines data and
models to study the effect of
international trade on labour markets
and technology adoption in developing
countries
we are particularly delighted to welcome
her because she will be
joining the ide program and teaching
macroeconomics in the fall
professor edward basha graduated from
the yale id program in 1965
and he was the first student from his
original training program in brazil to
be accepted in a doctoral program
after a single year of postgraduate uh
coursework
he continued on to ideal economics and
received his phd in 1968. he has taught
in
several universities both in the united
states and
brazil he's held positions as an
economist in policy making organizations
like the united nations and the world
bank
and he's particularly well known for
being part of a group of economists who
came up with a plan
based on virtual currency that succeeded
in slowing down brazil's rampant
inflation
in the 1990s so we're delighted that uh
professor bashar has joined us today
and i will hand it over to him now he
will give a presentation for
um around 20 to 25 minutes
followed by a discussion of first the
presentation
and then a q a with professor basha by
cecilia fowler and then after that we
opened for
q a we're delighted by the audience
that's joined us
we also realized that we may not be able
to get to all q and a's
but professor basha has uh kindly agreed
that if
as you write your questions you could
also provide your email address
then he would be very happy to respond
to them by email later
so professor basha thank you again for
joining us and over to you
pleasure
thank you very much it's a pleasure
to be back to hill house avenue after so
many years
even if it is only virtual i'm only
sorry that
after this we cannot go all together
either to peppers or salads
for a beer and a pizza but anyways
maybe next week we'll do that
my presentation today you know it's
based
on a paper that uh
we published in five years ago
it's a joint paper uh with my
dear late friend jesus bonnelli
and it was used to call as i read it
here
accounting for the rise and fall of
brazil's growth
after world war ii
but given that brazil has not improved
actually has
gotten worse you know since we finished
the paper
uh i decided to change the title to
something more
dramatic which is what's gone
wrong with brazil's economy
in my presentation it's
a story in four acts
i first are going to show you in one
slide
how far behind the us brazil has
stayed over time so giving you
a historical perspective then i'll focus
more in detail in the growth
collapse of brazil after 1980
formulate a hypothesis that we had in
this paper that i mentioned
for this collapse and provide some
arguments for this hypothesis and then
shift over to cecilia to see
what else she has to add start with this
comparison with the us
in this slide you know we see the ratio
of brazil's
to us per capita income all the way back
from 1820
to 2020. i
divided this periods here into
six politically important
appearance for brazil we
after we became independent of portugal
in 1822 we had the constitutional
monarchy which
lasted for most of the 19th century
then the big this we decided to imitate
the united states
and became presidentialist uh with the
first republic
we had the famous dictator retulio
vargas coming
for 15 years uh and then after he was
dismissed after the end of the second
world war we had this
second republic the militaries took over
again
in 1964 from the
um a follower of
vargas that was president at the time
they stayed on for 25 years
and since uh 1985 you know we have had
we we're having a democracy
even though we've all these difficulties
that we're having now
with the current president but anyways
in terms of this per capita income
comparisons of the us
you can see that you know as brazil
became independent uh
we the per capita income brazil was
something like
60 of the us uh
then by the end of the 19th century this
had gone down
to 30 percent it continued to decline
up until the 1920s brazil
started growing fast you know
the united states entered the uh the uh
the reset the the depression in 1930
uh but afterwards he recovered
very nicely during the world war so that
at the beginning of uh the period that
i'm going to consider
in the following you know 1945
brazil had a per capita income which was
only 20
of the us and then we started a catching
up period you know very hopeful
that so that by 1980 uh brazil's per
capita income had gone up
you know a little bit above 40 percent
of the us but then you know and this is
what i'm going to talk about
you know things have been going
downwards
mostly all the time and today we are
only at
something like 23 percent uh
the per capita income of the u.s
looking more specifically at the
post-war period
here in the second slide i show you
the brazil's gdp growth rate
uh from 1950 to 1920.
uh in blue uh the annual
gdp growth rate in orange
uh a 10-year moving average
as you can see from the 10-year moving
average you know
all the way for actually just from 1940
right
brazil was growing very nicely you know
over seven percent
uh this was up until close to
1980 there was a deceleration
around 75 but things you know if you
look at the
at the orange line sorry
there was a very deep uh
contraction of the economy it continues
to contract
up until 1990 that was the last decade
and then you know up and down a little
bit with the commodity
cycles and now you know
brazil has really after 1914
uh it tremendous bad period of which i'm
not going to talk much about you know
and over the last 10 years actually the
brazil
gdp growth rate has been zero
uh so but my point that i'm going to
discuss you know
what happened you know brazil was
growing so nicely
up until 1980 after the second world war
catching up
to the u.s and then apparently all of a
sudden you know
uh in fact as a function
of the a the the debt crisis of the
early 80s
uh brazil uh fell and uh
nevermore recovered you know we grew
seven and a half
uh and then start growing at two and a
half you know this is the
focus of the analysis that
follows and in order to analyze this you
know i use a very simple
gdp growth scheme you know let's say one
factor of production
growth scheme it's
gdp depends on the capital stock
in order to have capital stock to grow
we need savings and that's where the
process here
starts you know we start from savings
and depending what the capital goods
prices
are these savings motivate
an increase in the stock of capital
goods
and give this given this increase in the
stock of capital goods
depending on the productivity of capital
you get gdp growth you know this is
basically what i'm going to be
showing to you you know so there are
three fundamental variables here
uh to explain gdp growth
uh one is savings the order is the price
of
new capital goods that these savings are
buying
and then the productivity of these
capital goods in order to generate
gdp growth so there are three factors
here
uh that explain uh the
uh evolution of gdp growth we start to
live savings you know this is the
evolution
of the saving rates by periods from 1947
to 2000 and and 2020
divided in uh eight periods
uh from 1947 to 2010 again
and as you can see here you know what
you're going to focus on total savings
the domestic savings
is the orange line external savings are
the
is the blue line uh but i focus on the
dark line here for the total savings
you see that you know in this period up
until 1980
was a period of increasing savings
uh and from 1980s onwards is a period of
decreasing savings so
you can see you know savings was a fact
you know in this slowing down
of growth but if you take an average you
know 47 to 80
compared to 80 2020
the difference you know in terms of
averages we're looking at these
you know long historical periods the
difference in average is not very much
you know it's only seven percent you
know
you couldn't explain the drop of set
of gdp growth from seven and a half to
two and a half
uh on the basis of savings alone you
know it contributed but it contributed
i was going to argue no only marginally
more important
for what happened to gdp growth was the
cis factor which is the capital good
prices you know the ratio
of investment prices to the prices of
gdp
which is here we have the showing this
capital good prices you know an index uh
with the uh the price in 2000
equal to one uh i
and as you can see you know uh
i i had to adjust the edges
and i had to adjust this period that
have
adjusted prices here's a period of
hyperinflation
the national accounts went crazy too so
we just
forgot about the original price from the
national accounts and
make an adjustment here but anyways it
shows quite clearly you know which is a
very
unique uh phenomenon uh in brazil you
know if you compare
you don't find this in other countries
you know a very
substantial increase in the price
of capital goods uh throughout this
period
from the 1950s
up until the 80s
and this essentially you know
showed that you know if you compare now
the average price
of capital goods in the period of 1980
to 2019
you know this is 30 percent
3.0 percent higher
than it was in the period previous to
1980
so that was a very substantial part of
the explanation
that even those savings did not decline
much
the purchasing power of savings
over capital goods that declined
very substantially not because you had
less savings but you because the prices
of capital goods that the savings were
buying
increase so substantially the second
phenomenon
that explains the growth collapse is
capital productivity
shown in this slide from 1950
to 2020 this is
gdp divided by the stock of capital
and again you can see you know that
throughout this period up until 1980
there was a continuous decline in the
capital productivity
in brazil and the average
that we have in the period
after 1980 compared to the period
previous to 1980 is a
decline of 25 you know
so you see you know capital group the
data declined 25
the price of capital goods increased
30 and savings declined by 7
and all this to get put together you
know
is what explain why gdp growth
the decline from seven and a half
to two and a half when you compare pre
to post 1980 that's the fundamental
explanation that we elaborate in the
paper that i previously mentioned
i previously mentioned so
my conclusion here tentative because i'm
going to
try to substantiate in the following is
that the collapse
in gdp growth since 1980
had more to do with lower
capital productivity and higher capital
goods prices
than to reduce savings hypothesis
is that these two phenomena are
interconnected
they are a consequence of brazil
maintaining
its economy close to international trade
brazil deepened an inefficient import
substitution process instead
of promoting exports as the countries
that
overcame the so-called middle income
trap did
as i was shown in the following the
consequences
of this process of inefficient import
substitution
this deepening of this inefficient
import substitution process
the consequences where higher capital
good prices
and lower capital productivity i.e
lower gdp growth and i'm now
going to make some comparisons to
substantiate
this hypothesis the first comparison
that i make
is with brazil compared to south korea
here we have the ratio of brazil's
to south korea's per capita gdp
from 1950 to 2020.
as you can see up until
74 brazil had a higher
per capita income than south korea
but south korea started catching up you
know from the early
60s and then you know not only catched
up but
over past brazil and today you know
brazil gdp per capita
is only one third that of korea
why this happened you know there are
many explanations
in the literature the one that i like
best
is this one is
this graph show uh the trade ratios
meaning the sum of exports plus
imports over gdp of brazil
and south korea from 1953 to 2019
brazil is this solid line south korea
is the dotted line as you can see you
know up until
the early 60s both countries
were following the same import
substitution process
industrialization through import
substitution
but from the early 60s which is exactly
the point
from which south korea is start
taking off as i showed in the previous
slide south korea
is starting having a process of export
promotion
increasing the participation of trade
in gdp so that starting from something
like uh
seven percent in the early sixties south
korea's
uh trade ratio today is something like
a hundred and ten percent while
brazil which had you know five percent
trade ratio in the early 60s only grew
very very slowly and today as a trade
ratio exports
plus imports over gdp of only
24 brazil remained
closed while south korea opened up
it's not only south korea actually
the 12 countries that overcame the
middle
income trap after world war
all of them did so by
integrating into the world economy
as the trade to gdp the last column
in this table clearly show let's focus
on the median
the trade to gdp median
ratio the trade to gdp uh
ratio me the median of that for these
countries is 77
compared to brazil 24. uh these
countries are
three times more open than brazil is
and look at that you know they now are
the first column gdp per capita
in thousand dollars these countries have
a
per capita income of 43 000
compared to brazil 15 000. all three
times higher
again you know this is a very nice
coincidence that i like it
it's interesting these countries you
know why
the way they integrated to the world
economy were different you know
some exported industry south korea hong
kong
israel singapore taiwan
some exported services spain
greece ireland portugal and some
exported natural resources
norway australia new zealand
the way they did it depend their
comparative advantages you know but they
that was one fundamental characteristic
of all this country is that in order
to be now rich
compared to the fact that there were
middle class
previous to the world war second world
war
the reason is that they participate
very substantially in the
world economy as shown by this trade to
gdp ratios
in contrast to brazil and why is so
important and now i'm going to conclude
you know
to participate in the world economy in
order to grow
it is because growth is essentially
productivity
gains and after you reach middle class
after you have all your population in
urban sectors you know the only way to
have productivity gains
is to participate international trade
why is that because international trade
allows you the adoption
state-of-the-art technology modern
capital goods
productive capital goods cheap
capital goods it allows you the
generation
of economies of scale because you're not
limited
to the domestic market you have all the
wood at your disposition
and allows you to specialization in
lines of production in which
the country has a comparative advantage
you
and also equally important
it gives you market competition you know
survival of the fittest which is a
fundamental test for increasing
productivity
and allowing gdp growth
something that brazil unfortunately
did not do and this is why basically
i would like to submit to you we are now
in this situation
that we cannot find way out a way out
in order to recover a more decent
growth rate as we had in the past
obrigado
so i would like to start by thanking
professor basha for the wonderful
presentation
and for accepting the invitation from
the ide
and also remind the audience that the
chat is close to them so please post
your questions on the
q a what i'll do next
yes should i stop sharing you're going
to use my
i'm not going to use the screen so these
are some of the questions are about
the um your presentation you may want to
bring them back
what i'm going to do is just briefly
summarize my research
and that will naturally bring in some
questions to
professor basha as he highlighted in his
presentation
international trade was a linchpin of
economic policy
in virtually all the countries that grew
sustainably after world war
ii and my research delves into firm
level data
precisely to understand the mechanisms
through which international trade
affects economic development
especially in developing countries so
when a firm
from a developing country engages in
international trade
whether through imports of intermediate
inputs or exports
with developed countries trade
of a firm it typically upgrades the
quality of its products
technologies and management practices
firms and developed countries are
generally more advanced
and there are several reasons why they
may want their trading partners to also
upgrade their quality for example the
automated production process
typically requires precise specification
for parts
and the higher quality materials just in
time and venturing management and
integrated computer systems
require trading partners to be organized
and flexible with their deliveries
billings and even product specifications
after all
adapting to shocks is one of the main
advantages of just in time
this upgrading of quality among
importers and exporters is well
documented in the literature
what's less well known is that for the
same
reasons the importers and exporters as
they upgrade
they also require their trading partners
domestically
to upgrade and these importers and
exporters tend to be very large firms
and so even a relatively small amount of
international trade
may have a large effect on the domestic
market this amplification effect is
particularly felt in the labor market
because more advanced technologies feed
them
programmable machineries margin
management practices they all complement
skilled workers
many countries in africa and the middle
east and latin america including brazil
itself
that liberalized international trade in
the 1980s and 90s
saw the wages of their college graduates
increase
by 10 to 20 percent relative to their
less skilled
workers so very dramatic increase in
inequality in just a few
years the demand for skills in
manufacturing
also went up dramatically in south korea
and other southeast asian countries
but what these countries did differently
was that they invested very heavily in
education
the manufacturing sector grew adopted
better practices invested
and improved their productivity and
arguably also had
large positive effects on the rest of
the economy while brazil
and other latin american economies firms
also
upgraded and became more skill intensive
but they became more skill intensive
by shedding their unskilled workers
mostly to the informal sector
manufacturing the manufacturing sectors
professor basha has himself
documented decrease in brazil from 25
percent
of gdp to 15 percent
and it didn't have the same positive
effects in the blessed economy
so the second difference between east
asia and latin america is that east asia
promoted its exports
and engaged in international production
chains
while brazil and other latin american
countries similarly
they lowered their trade tariffs but
their infrastructure remained decrepit
their ports corrupted
and this makes the cost in timing of the
flow of goods into the country
high and unpredictable which makes it
very difficult for brazilian firms
to engage in international production
chains when
you need good goods to come in and out
of the country
in a predictable and less costly
way especially when firms and the rest
of the world are trying to maintain
lean inventories so putting this
research background
together with professor basha's work
leads to
a few questions so first is that i just
suggested that that
and again professor basha has insisted
in his previous work
that in order to fully take advantage of
international trade and growth prospects
the country needs to invest in
infrastructure and education professor
basha shows however in previous work
that the tax burden in brazil is high
for
a country of its income level in most of
this tax revenue is absorbed into the
pension and payroll
system so um professor basha can you
tell us a little bit
about structural reforms in particular
the recent reforms
of the pension system how deep was it
and
is the administrative reform politically
viable so that resources can be freed up
for
infrastructure and education
uh cecilia thank you for a very good
compliment
i settled stimulated to read more of
your
research and integrate this your results
into my
uh my my own my own work
and uh the er comments you know about
that
uh that that are all other factors
besides uh opening to trade you know
in order to explain i i brought some
additional slide
just in case you know which essentially
i are directed uh to this
process if i can move here too
yes you know that's opening up to
international trade is a necessary
condition but it's not sufficient you
know
and this you know if you you you can see
you know if you are
if you are a big in a nico country
like mexico is same as brazil you know
mexico
with nafta open up to international
trade very nicely you know
it used to have twenty percent trade
ratios is not have seventy percent
while brazil you know used to have 10
it's now at that 24.
but nonetheless you know the growth
experiences of both
mexico and brazil are very similar you
know
mexico also was growing fast up until
maybe and then
sunk you know and never saw uh
growth resume and anymore you know not
even
uh with nafta helping along
and this means that other factors
intervene as far as you know when
you are both big and nico and one
of them as you mentioned is education or
education
quality in brazil according to the pisa
2015
is very bad you know in science sorry
for being this in portuguese but you
know
that's the way it is uh in science
in reading in mathematics brazil is
way down you know in terms of the
rating that brazilian students
get in this in this international
competition and it's not so much
you know the question of education is
spending you know in the
in the horizontal hacks you have
education and spending per people
very important we can't see your new
slides
i don't think i'm sorry can you see what
your slides we don't see it
they're not showing no
not any of them i don't see them maybe
um someone else in the panel can
intervene if they see it
a bit no i can't see it
sorry no we can't see it
um oh oh
anyway i'm sorry i think you can
describe
they're gonna describe here but anyway
this is the uh
there's a graph that showed education is
spending per pupil
compared to the piece of results you
know and brazil even though
it's it's spend you know normally for
its income level
but the quality of its educational
it does not show in the results you know
chile
spends as much as brazil uruguay
and they have a much better results
in pisa than brazil has uh
and uh so the education quality not only
spending is very important
the other factor is the very low quality
of infrastructure
this that this picture that you're not
seeing
and also the low quality of
infrastructure
in the greek countries uh let me see if
i can do something here
sorry
is that better though no maybe if you
send an email to
scott with the presentation attached
that he can
share it
professor bashar are these on youtube
are these on your additional slides
yeah what about this now
no i think you're sharing the wrong
screen
well okay anyways so i i'm sure that
infrastructure you know
brazil is the worst of the bricks
and uh and then the next one is just to
show brazil has very taxed
very high tax rates we we
tax brazilians more than the japanese
tax
the japanese we tax brazilians more than
the
americans tax the amer the u.s tax the
americans
so even though we have a tax rate which
is very high
which is concentrated in indirect taxes
not in direct taxes
all of these go into pension spending
brazil
is the country that relative to this
dependency ratio
the ratio of old to young people is the
country that spends more
in the world in terms of pensions you
know we spend
nothing we spend something like 15 of
gdp
on on pensions and we also spend very
substantially
with public servants uh
13 of gdp only south africa spends more
than us
and when you add up you know dispensers
of the government
with pensions and with
civil servants you know they get to near
to 80 percent of the total budget
so there is very little left
in in terms of
in terms of uh terminology here
in terms of uh alternatives
uh for for the government to spend in
you know even improving the quality of
education also the quantity
of education in in health in education
and uh in uh and in infrastructure
so basically you know besides having an
inefficient
private sector because it's not
integrated into the world economy
we have a bloated public sector
so we besides you know opening up
we also need a very substantial reform
you know
administrative reform and they reform
in their tax system in order to
be able you know to provide education
and infrastructure in order to
complement
what against that we would observe in
case brazil
finally decides to open up
okay just a short point on education you
know it's a little bit outside your
research
but um you correctly mentioned that
it's not so much the amount of spending
i think the us has the same issue
but it's the quality have you seen any
or are there any types of policy to try
to improve the
quality that you find particularly
persuasive
in terms of improving education
you know they are they have there are
lots of
uh uh experiments
uh in brazil you know especially when
the state of
a poor state of sierra a particular
state of the interior of sierra which is
called sobral
you know uh which has a a
a a a
behavior in terms of the quality of
spread of of education
that's substantially higher than any
anywhere else in brazil you know and
they didn't do
no magic you know they just uh they had
a
stimulus plan uh the state
gave back some taxes to
uh to the cities and towns
that improve their education performance
you know that uh you know
money uh helps they also
uh look very careful in terms of the you
know the size of classes the quality of
the teachers
and especially you know the quality of
the directors of the primary schools
so you know it can be done and the
problem really is you know not so much
then you know in terms of uh
spending though you know we do need some
of that you know
but it's how would it be possible
to emulate and to use these
experiences that you have you know a
spiritual center which is another poor
state
also had a tremendous improvement in the
educational system you know
so it can be done you know uh i think
it's
fundamentally a question of political
will
it's very difficult um let me go back
to the question of openness and
differences in policy between
latin america and asia so you were one
of the architects of
the real plan as rohini mentioned
and which successfully ended the
brazilian struggle with inflation
for which my generation is very grateful
and
the plan in 1994 came shortly after
the 1991 trade globalization it involved
the
tighter monetary policy and resulted in
the real
exchange rate appreciation this made it
difficult for
brazilian firms to compete with imports
and exports and to export their output
now if brazil were to open up more for
international trade
today is it viable for it
to follow the example of east asia and
maintain its exchange rate devalued
without inflation picking up again
what's your take on that
yeah you know that was a very
unfortunate uh
coincidence of uh experiments you know
because
we there was an opening up
in 1990 which was going
relative well you know with some uh
sector
and regional difficulties but overall
it was improving but then you know we
had the
system which was a fixed exchange rate
system in the period you know
first it was a parity with the dollar
and
and then when we made the real plan the
real plan was very successful though
but it had to rely you know in order to
keep inflation down
on an exchange rate anchor so
and that exchange required low profits
provide
uh produced an overvaluation of the
currency
so that on top of the decline in tariffs
we also have an over the overvaluation
of the currency
which you know submitted their domestic
producers
to very strong pressures and they
eventually know got together
and managed to have the country to
reverse
the opening up that we had in 1990
so one lesson of this period you know
don't do don't try to open up and revive
your currency at the same time you know
fortunately now we have a a floating
exchange rate
you know so what you would expect
uh in the case of opening up you know
is that you know as the financial sector
anticipates
a flood of imports and that in the in
the consequence you know demand for
dollars
the financial sector itself you know
would anticipate
this demand for dollars and would
devalue the currency you know
so that could be you know a natural
consequence of the workings
of a floating exchange rate but anyways
you know
currently this is not an issue you know
because
for reasons that uh i think the
international press
are propagating quite well you know the
disgrace that
is this government is you know we have
the over devalued
currency today you know they pursue
three years three years ago you know the
real was worth uh
uh we need three three gray eyes for the
dollar you know
and now we need uh five and a half per
eyes for the dollars so you know
brazil has a very substance is
impossible now
you know to allege that the exchange
rate is not
competitive is extremely competitive
and this should provide a very good
occasion to open me up
that's it that's right i want to go on
vacation as soon as corvette
he gives us a reprieve
yeah so um it is
true just a short comment on what you've
just
the point you've just made that
naturally opening up to trade that
coming in from imports
tends to put pressure downwards and the
exchange rates should devalue
but the other hand hopefully it fosters
investment which tends to push it
up a little bit but you're right that at
the moment it doesn't seem to be
an issue at all um let me
i think we're 10 minutes away and i see
there are quite a few
questions in the q a um so i'd like to
turn to the audience
more so i guess i can
yes sorry i uh yes uh scott i don't know
if you've
selected i was just trying to stop that
that screen share we do have quite a few
questions coming in
thank you both for the really engaging
uh lecture and
discussion so far uh our first question
comes from actually one of our current
ide students
beatrice nunez professor basha
um we have a more specific question
regarding the urv
why did the real plan use one virtual
currency and one
physical currency instead of two
physical currencies
well the the original plan you know that
it's called the larida land
as rudy darbush named it you know it was
presented in 1985
in washington uh had this idea of you
know letting two currencies circulate
simultaneously you know
one is the old currency that is
depreciating the order that
was you know indexed to the dollar and
then people would shift
from the old currency to the new
currency and
once this process was sufficiently
advanced you know
inflation would have disappeared
the problem is that to have a
simultaneous
circulation of two currencies though
it's very complicated no
it's not even clear that this is
constitutional
so we we decided that it would
complicated too much you know
people we had a very bad experience
in czech slovakia in 1944
when they had this two current system
and they had the highest
hyperinflation award up until zimbabwe
came up on the way recently uh so we
decided you know rather than
have we have a you have a pre-currency
uh together with the old currency you
know is the pre-currency
uh the unit of real value
whose value was one dollar and then we
allowed you know uh first we
decreed a force change
of wages into the new currency according
in order to maintain the same parity
that the wage had over time
under high inflation and also we
converted some other things like
rents and school fees
according to according to the law but
then we allow for a four-month period
for everyone else you know to change uh
their contracts uh into
urvs you know uh and after we are
satisfied you know there are
sufficiently
people converting uh into rvs you know
actually one of our colleagues
though said that he believed that the
plan was a success
that once he was going to the beach to
the ipanema beach
and he looked at a stand you know and
saw that the price of one cocoa
was one dollar so if you want coconut
you know
was one dollar sorry not one dollar one
rv
so that even the guy who's selling
coconuts in the beach you know
understand what the urv
was we were ready uh
to do the shift you know and that's why
we uh
we made this you know in this process
you know we're very successful
actually you know the public
broadcasting system
um has a a broadcast
a data phase is available on youtube if
you want to read you know
it's they had a very bad title you know
i i i complained to them
but they did not change you know it's
all for
drinking bodies uh
managed to uh stop the inflation in the
country you know
so anyway so uh that's
basically the reason though you don't
you they do currency system is very
complicated to do you know
so we did it half of the suggestion and
i think that was very good
i mean personally i think that's a great
uh title for an article so i i would be
honored if i were you
we we have another great question from
one of our participants uh ravisha gupta
with covid related disruptions in global
supply chains
now may be a good time for countries in
latin america and sub-saharan africa
to enter these chains and open up to
more trade
what would be some requisite domestic
features at the country level
for this to happen and are there any
countries doing this right now
well right now you know that's a big
discussion here you know that the people
protectionists you know are saying see
this guy who want to open up you know uh
if you are dependent on foreigners there
when
we need them most you know is what
is where they do they don't have the
things available you know like
difficulties or getting vaccines in
brazil
it's not even getting the vaccines they
get the inputs to the vaccines you know
uh
so uh overview there's this tremendous
protectionism in the u.s now you know
that has so many vaccines you know
it's not using uh astrazeneca i know
there's 30 million
sitting down i don't know where you know
why don't you give it to
to to other countries you know that are
there will be very happy in brazil
to use the astrazenecas that are sitting
up
in the u.s you know a lot of being used
and also
probably becoming uh
become useless you know because of the
data fabrication
so you know the question but the
otherwise you know what people really
see you know
from with those who are not extreme
protectionists you know
it's how important is international
collaboration
you know how important are these
integration
uh in order to produce you know this
this successful vaccines that we have
now you know
uh they they the
advisor you know it's it's just half
germans is half americans it's
as a substantial component of chinese
you know
and so and this is true you know people
i think that are in uh in the met in
in in labs uh the pharmaceutical
industry here in brazil
they very they very practically know
they cannot do it alone you know they
don't want protection
they want to have ways of integrating
and
support of the government for innovation
you know
like uh the warp speed process did uh
you know brazil cannot afford a warp
speed
obviously but obviously this is the way
supporting innovation that the way to
going
ahead professor feeler do you have any
uh
thing to add on this no i fully
agree with professor basha that
um the world especially from the
perspective of developing countries
are actually gaining from the
development of
new vaccines coming in from the u.s yeah
the u.s england
and other countries that themselves are
not vaccines
coming from insular countries but coming
in from scientists from all over the
world and parts from all over the world
so
um yes i don't really have much to add
there
all right thank you well so we only have
time for a couple of more questions
maybe one or two more
i'm just gonna ask we have a a one just
came in from eduardo
costa uh professor basha in your view
what's the possible or potential
contribution
that the brazilian amazon region can
make to the economic growth and
development of brazil
there's a brazilian scientist dr nobre
who refers to
amazon 4.0 as possible new wave of
innovation and productivity
based on sustainable use of biodiversity
resources in the amazon
to produce marketable products how do
you see amazon making a contribution
in the world in the near future well
first of all you have to put pressure
on the current government in order to
stop destroying amazon you know
this is the first line of defense you
know if we're going to
have the amazon you know we have to make
sure
uh that that the destructive policy of
this government
is stopped in its tracks you know
uh we were successful you know uh
in uh in one aspect which is getting rid
of the foreign
foreign foreign the foreign minister
here
which was a crazy man you know but also
the current the minister of uh
uh the mayumbi entity
the means of uh that deals with the
amazon now
it's also no way in the gas industry no
he does not believe in
in this uh in in global warming
he wants uh and bolsonaro is obviously a
stupid person
uh he wants to develop the amazon or he
could destroy it all you know
in order to have it uh for development
the way that
we did in nineteenth century the u.s did
in the 19th century we did it you know
for most of the 20th century uh he would
go ahead you know so we have to stop
these guys first you know
and for that uh the pressure of the
international community
is very important second you know
there's this whole question of if you
have a reasonable
government suppose we can find biden or
biden you know
uh in 202
181
[Music]
what should we do about the amazon first
of all
you know we have to find a way to get
rid of the zona franca de manaus you
know which
is a place in manaus which produces
uh industrial goods very expensive
it then actually is say it's thing
that's only serves you know that you
import the components
you fabricate the product you know the
by
bicycle for example and then you shift
it to sao paulo
you know it's just a way of uh
is just a way of uh
making it more expensive industrial
products
that we could have more easily without
this intermediation
but then you have to put something
instead there right
and the people in the amazon say well
there's
if people don't fabricate these goods
you know they're going to destroy the
forest
so we have to find an alternative
employment for these people you know
there are lots of people in the amazon
you know it's 20 million people
i don't know if the amazon can carry 20
million people you know
perhaps we should in the process no
think of
ways uh because of biotechnology you
know people are very sad oh the forest
is
fully off uh these new products that
uh you know that that
that we could use and yes i think there
are some there you know
but not sufficient to make 20 people 20
million people
uh sufficiently productive sufficiently
uh even income sufficiently high so
we have to find you know a combination
no
of preservation but in order to preserve
we have to
pay off these people who are there
and who know who who would not find the
productive
employment in a way that is consistent
with the preservation of the forest
rohini i'm just checking in to see if
you had anything to add here before we
uh
we wrap up i see that we're we're
getting to time
yeah no i think this was uh
a fascinating discussion i learned a lot
so
um thank you to both professor basha and
professor
feeler and we hope we will be able to
meet
on campus in the fall or sometime soon
we also too thank you for organizing
this
okay and the campus in the campus and
that's sally's
and peppers exactly
thank you very much thank you